economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado de
nicaragua para el mundo jorge comenzamos
hablando de eeuu y esa discusión que hay
sobre el techo de la deuda del país
bueno del presidente de eeuu joe biden a
leer todos las consecuencias económicas
que tendría la suspensión de pagos- en
ese país vaivén acusó a los republicanos
de actuar de forma irresponsable y
peligrosa según él al negarse a elevar
el techo de la deuda una discusión que
tiene como fecha tope el 18 de octubre
escuchemos
una suspensión de pagos- amenazaría el
estatus del dólar como divisa de reserva
de la que depende el mundo y se
rebajaría la nota de solvencia de eeuu
además de aumentar las tasas de interés
para hipotecas préstamos de automóviles
o tarjetas de crédito
santiago y es que el techo de la deuda
es una legislación que permite al
gobierno pedir crédito o bonos sin la
autorización del congreso siempre que no
rebase el límite que ya ha sido
establecido la legislación ha sido
modificada varias veces principalmente
cada vez que el gobierno necesita más
dinero para su funcionamiento el último
aumento fue en 2019 cuando subió a 22
mil billones de dólares pero actualmente
la deuda de eeuu supera los 28 billones
de dólares y nunca será suficiente para
ellos el tope que establezcan hablemos
de la crisis por la falta de
profesionales que continúan el reino
unido- particularmente entre los
transportistas bueno este lunes
militares británicos comenzaron a
distribuir combustible en la gasolinera
de reino unido para tratar de paliar la
crisis de suministro a pesar de que el
gobierno asegura que la reserva de
gasolina y diésel son suficiente la
falta de mano de obra en el sector
transporte afectó a los distribuidores y
disparó la demanda por el temor al
desabastecimiento la causa del
desabastecimiento de combustible se debe
a la escasez de conductores de camiones
cisterna muchos trabajadores de la
cadena de suministro de varios sectores
económicos procedían del continente y
ahora no tienen permisos para trabajar
en reino unido desde el prsc en londres
y en el sureste de inglaterra
hay más de un 20% de gasolineras
clausuradas y esta crisis de transporte
golpea otros sectores como la
alimentación que advirtió de problemas
para surtir de jamón pavo o cerdos
durante la época navideña y también
afecta al sector aeronáutico hablemos de
las reacciones en américa latina' a la
investigación de los papeles de pandora
bueno esta vez el presidente chileno
sebastián piñera rechazó un conflicto de
interés en la venta de la minera dominga
por parte de la empresa de sus hijos la
investigación lo involucre en la venta
de la minera en 2010 a uno de sus amigos
más cercanos y agrega que el negocio
contenía una polémica cláusula que
supeditaba el último pago a que no se
estableciese un área de protección
ambiental sobre la zona de operaciones
de la minera como reclaman grupos
ambientalistas veamos que dijo
la decisión de la administración
de esas empresas de vender dinero
dominga el año 2010 lo cual no nos fue
consultado en informado fue precisamente
para evitar cualquier asomo de conflicto
de interés el 9 lo hecho podría haber
originado algún conflicto de interés ni
mi familia ni yo tenemos sociedades de
inversión constituidas el extranjero
porque hablando de otras noticias
destacadas del día la calidad de los
principales productos o redes de
facebook generó caos mundial así es una
venta masiva hizo que las acciones de
facebook cayeran alrededor del 5 por
ciento este lunes y que sumado una caída
del 15 por ciento desde mediados de
septiembre lo hizo perder millones de
dólares el patrimonio personal de mack
zuckerberg el fundador de facebook se
redujo en casi 6 mil millones de dólares
en las últimas horas y lo bajó del
ranking de las personas más ricas del
mundo el apagón de redes sociales
coincide con la denuncia de frança hoy
en la ex gerente de producto de facebook
que filtró documentos que según ella
evidencia en que esta empresa puso el
crecimiento por encima de la seguridad
facebook ha dicho que la filtración es
engañosa y este descenso supone que la
fortuna de zuckerberg haya quedado en
117 mil millones de dólares lo que lo
relega el sexto puesto de las personas
más ricas del mundo 117 mil millones
pues indicadores como les fue en las
bolsas precisamente con este panorama
que nos explicaba bueno en eeuu la
jornada fue negativa para el sector
tecnológico por la rotación de mercado
la subida del interés de la deuda
pública y los problemas de facebook en
europa la bolsa cerraron a la baja al
pendiente de la reunión de la opep
respecto a la producción de petróleo y
en américa latina hubo leves caídas
arrastradas por el resto de las bolsas
del mundo y para el cierre la cifra del
día sorpréndanos 210 mil 100 millones de
dólares eran las pérdidas por la
pandemia para el sector aéreo hasta 2022
según la asociación internacional del
transporte aéreo este monto santiago es
el acumulado del 2020 2021 y 2022 muchas
gracias jorge por esta actualización del
mundo económico es todo por el momento
aquí en france24 siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]